Hello everyone in this short series
video we will try to identify some
solutions to improve to improve
the user experience of yours
android applications
the goal of the videos and provide one
overview of the main ones
problems and report some
practical advice not clearly of
exhaustively investigate i
user experience concepts is more ai
We will mainly focus on design
on some patterns recommended by
official android guide to solve
the classic problems in dealing with it
development in designing the experience on
mobile devices here in this slide vi
mark it with the useful links you will find many
information clearly on the website of
android developer the official guide of
of google for android for
android developers
specifically for the topics that
we will discuss excellent insights there
are in the sections design is a pattern
let's start now with a brief overview on
some basic user concepts
experience
starting from the mental model that in good order
substance is the mental model that
the user creates completely
automatic thinking about the use it will make
your application imagines them
functionality and flow to achieve
certain goals
the inter
the graphics are the user experience yours
app should get as close as possible
to what is the mental model he has
created the user in his head
this thing starts since when
looked at the icon in the play store
in practice the management and the way
defines a scheme of actions from
which user expects feedback and
to achieve certain goals
here it becomes of absolute importance
determine precisely what they are
user goals in use
in using your app
an application that does very well the
own operations for which it was
designed works better than an app that does
more or less enough
operations often in drawing
the experience for my applications me
I entrust to those who are called the
people cruisers or profiles
fictitious real people who could
use the application surname name
age what it does in life and habits e
passions at this point will be much more
easy to focus on
the goal that these people have
in using ours clearly
limit yourself to only one profile help in
initial phase
if the scec julius kaiser of ours
app increases increases the complexity yes
prefers to use three four
profiles to monitor better is for
see the different ones better I scales this
it is a practical advice when starting a
design an android application
probably one of the hardest things to
digest for a programmer we would like
all immediately throw ourselves headlong into the
the programming perceive the results
real of our code efforts
in the device however with increasing
of the complexity of the aps and the phase of
design was not addressed in
appropriate way we will meet big
problems
the advice I give is to use gods
warfare and demo cup often this thing
it is underestimated but has a pattern
clear and highly faithful to the result
that you want to get will help you
write the best code and avoid
a factually expensive factoring in
some cases then play all the
views of your app experiences i
various flows of operations
maybe this whole project
reproducing the user experience
ok once it's your wireframe not
it's over here if you're thinking that you
you can write the first one
activity for your app actually can
do one more thing about user tests
real with real users is done
attest the trouble frame the flow that you
it is meant for real users if you are
asking why in this operation
necessary well basically a good one
reason could be to avoid
to upset the logic of ours
application because maybe users
don't grab some components well for
how we thought of them
at the beginning so quite
the various views are simple
users and make themselves determined
operations without guiding the user into
in the flow flow without correcting it
continually it is usually five tests
they are more than enough to identify
of the criticalities for the tests and then
use one of the reported tools
in the article in the article recreate yours
flows using simple sheets of
post it all card to create one
simple beauty of your application
we give very fast or even use the
classic rounds of prototyping like
Balsamiq